vamos a las noticias de la economía con
Jorge Hurtado Buen día para usted Jorge
Buenos días Ángela una feliz mañana y
vamos a iniciar en la eurozona donde el
dato de la inflación está suponiendo un
dilema para las autoridades monetarias
bueno Y esto Pese a que la inflación
general bajó cayó al
5,5% en junio el dato subyacente subió
la inflación anual de la zona de la
moneda única bajó desde el 6,1% que
había registrado en mayo hasta el 5,5
ahora en junio pero la inflación
subyacente este dato que excluye la
energía o los precios de la energía y
los alimentos fue del 5,4% frente al 5,3
que había registrado en mayo esa es una
mala noticia para el Banco Central
europeo esto porque es la señal que
probablemente estaban esperando para
seguir subiendo los tipos de interés
hasta que la presión en este índice
subyacente comience a descender hacia su
objetivo del 2% inicial la inflación
cayó en 18 de los 20 países de la
eurozona aumentó en Alemania y se está
encuentro hacia el aumento de los
precios cayó por debajo del objetivo del
2% del Banco Central europeo en países
como España Bélgica y Luxemburgo por
primera vez en un año la inflación en la
eurozona ha caído un poco más lento que
como lo ha hecho en Estados Unidos donde
fue del 4% en mayo vamos a seguir
hablando de inflación porque en Alemania
como usted decía subió Así es bueno
según los datos publicados por la
oficina de estadísticas la inflación
anual en Alemania alcanzó el 6,4% en
junio los datos de junio muestran que
allí la inflación repuntó después de
caer durante al menos tres meses
consecutivos la inflación subyacente
subió al 5,8% un 0,4% más que el mes
anterior el aumento de los precios de
los alimentos sigue siendo el mayor
impulsor de la inflación en el mes otro
dato importante y preocupante para
Alemania es que la agencia crediticia
alemana Credit dice que las empresas
alemanas que entraron en insolvencia
aumentó en la primera mitad de este año
debido a la crisis energética la
inflación y también este aumento
generalizado de los tipos de interés en
el mundo el número de grandes empresas
insolventes con más de 250 empleados
aumentó un 67% respecto al mismo periodo
del año pasado para un dato todavía más
desalentador es que el de medianas
empresas quebradas que tienen entre 51 y
250 empleados aumentó un 133% anual bien
y en otras noticias el Ministerio de
asuntos exteriores de China ya emitió su
reacción a los planes de Estados Unidos
y también de Países Bajos de restringir
las exportaciones de chips al gigante
asiático bueno Y esto como parte de un
nuevo capítulo en esta guerra comercial
entre Estados Unidos y el gigante
asiático y sobre todo en este sector tan
clave y delicado como es el de los
microconductores Estados Unidos y los
Países Bajos quieren limitar las ventas
a los fabricantes de Chip chinos en el
marco de este esfuerzo por impedir que
su tecnología según occidente se utili
para reforzar al ejército chino sobre
esto se pronunció la vocera del
Ministerio de asuntos exteriores chinos
Mao ni escuchamos lo que dijo china
siempre se ha opuesto a que la parte
estadounidense generalice el concepto de
seguridad nacional abuse de los
controles a la exportación utilice
diversas excusas para engatusar o
coaccionar a otros países a participar
en un bloqueo científico y tecnológico
contra China y aplique la intervención
administrativa en los intercambios
económicos y comerciales normales entre
empresas lo que socaba gravemente las
reglas del mercado el orden económico y
comercial internacional e incide en la
estabilidad de la cadena mundial de
producción y suministro y no beneficia a
ninguna de las partes y en otros temas
Jorge Ucrania va a recibir otro
importante apoyo para su reconstrucción
esta noticia me parece Pues un poco
contradictoria sobre todo cuando ocurre
a una guerra y cuando intentan
reconstruir parte esta infraestructura
crítica que se seguía instruyendo a
diario por los misiles los bombardeos y
por la misma guerra serán 1500 millones
de dólares del Banco Mundial según el
Primer Ministro de según el según estos
funcionarios estos fondos Serán emitidos
como garantías el gobierno japonés y se
van a canalizar Para apoyar la seguridad
social y el desarrollo económico la
junta del fondo monetario internacional
completó su revisión para este préstamo
lo que le permite kiev retirar
inmediatamente unos 890 millones de
apoyo presupuestario el año pasado es
economía cayó alrededor de un tercio
debido a la guerra de Rusia contra
Ucrania y está trabajando con los socios
extranjeros para asegurar el
financiamiento para esta denominada
recuperación rápida así le han llamado
las autoridades el dinero será destinado
a reconstruir escuelas hospitales
carreteras y puentes así como los daños
en este sector energético a pesar de los
combates que todavía se desarrollan en
el sur y en el este del país O sea
tienen que continuar es como si
estuvieran muy confiados en que van a
tener la victoria Jorge Pero además es
que el flujo de financiación en Ucrania
parecen no tener límites es sin duda
parte del apoyo de occidente para que de
alguna forma se rápidamente de esta
tragedia que es una guerra y sin embargo
sabe que muchos expertos dicen que hoy
en día es imposible ganar una guerra de
cualquier naturaleza en cualquier parte
del mundo así que bueno es un punto
muerto si le parece bien vamos a pasar
ahora noticias de América Latina
Argentina anunció que va a utilizar
yuanes para pagar al FM y vencimientos
por 2700 millones de dólares y esto trae
otros anuncios también del país
latinoamericano así lo confirmó la
portavoz Gabriela cerruti para que
Argentina pueda pagar parte de la
préstamo de 44 mil millones de dólares
otorgado en 2018 va a usar derechos
especiales de giro del tesoro y también
joanes Argentina renegocia con el fondo
monetario internacional este acuerdo de
facilidades extendidas que fue firmado
en marzo del año pasado Por lo cual se
refinanció el crédito de 2018 de 44 mil
millones de dólares Argentina quiere
modificar las condiciones de este
acuerdo para poder hacer frente a los
desequilibrios fiscales y la escasez de
dólares argumentando Pues esta fuerte
sequía que vive el país los yuanes
vendrían del Swap de Divisas con China y
le permitirá rellenar este hueco de las
pérdidas que tiene el Banco Central
escuchamos parte del anuncio estilo de
economía anunció que mañana se va a
realizar el pago que correspondía al
fondo monetario internacional por ese
segundo trimestre un pago de 2.700
millones de dólares que se va a pagar en
parte con derechos especiales de giro
del tesoro y en parte con yuanes de
libre disponibilidad con esto se hace un
pago que cumple con lo que habría que
había acordado con el fondo monetario y
al mismo tiempo no van a utilizarse
reservas ni un cambio de Divisas que ya
se venía anunciando y que varios países
Quieren poner en marcha Muchas gracias a
usted Jorge De nada nos vemos en la
próxima hora pero claro aquí lo espero